in the Northwest Territories of Canada
alone geologists Labour's away with
hammer and chisel struggling to extract
a sample of rock from a smooth
unyielding surface it's late in the
afternoon but she doesn't need to worry
about night falling in the summer field
season the Sun is never far from the
horizon and a pinkish Twilight rains
[Music]
field work in this corner of the globe
is a unique challenge there are no roads
out here no cafes or hotels no help if
anything goes wrong this is the land of
lakes and bears and the geologists are
far from home they traveled to this spot
first by float plane and then on foot
navigating with one eye on the
treacherous swampy ground the other
continually on the GPS it would be all
too easy to lose your way out here the
spot they are aiming for looks much like
any other in this wilderness but the
geologists maps reveal what the eye
cannot the nature of the rocks beneath
their feet the geologists task is to map
the changes and figure out the processes
that shaped this remote corner of the
globe this is the Canadian Shield a
fragment of ancient continental crust
finally on the shores of a shallow lake
they stop to the South stands of trees
of the Canadian boreal forest March into
the distance but to the north the Arctic
tundra is host to lower more Hardy
vegetation this whole area lies under
many feet of snow and ice in the winter
now the ice is gone but the geologists
still struggled to find the rock beneath
multicolored lygian which covers every
surface in a thick durable crust only
where fires have swept through all frost
has shattered the surface are we able to
see through to the ancient rocks
themselves the surface is smooth
polished as if by some immense giant
sweat stone but this is the handiwork of
Galatia s' passing through whose
incredible force is enough to grind
solid rock to powder and then use that
powder to grind the rocks some more
erosion by this by ice water wind will
be the fate of all rocks eventually but
this outcrop so far survives
this is what geologists call an ice a
metamorphic rock with an eventful
history one that is borne witness to the
convulsions of the earth on a massive
scale over hundreds of millions of years
as continents collided the granite was
crushed ached folded twisted out of all
recognition when it's finally uplifted
and exposed at the surface the result is
this intricately striated rock which
wears the scars of its torment as a
badge of identity certainly it's a
beautiful Rock it looks like many other
gneisses all over the world starting out
as igneous rock a granite that froze
from magma at the heart of an ancient
volcano but this nice this hard worn
specimen from the far reaches of Canada
is special it has seen more history than
any other rock on earth
when the geologist returned her precious
samples to the lab when she carefully
extracted the most resilient zircons and
when she precisely measured the
proportions of decayed and undecayed
uranium atoms she was finally able to
figure out its immense age for this is
the Acosta nice and it is four billion
years old it is the oldest rock on earth
[Music]
in its four billion years of the surface
of the planet it's withstood the
cataclysmic collisions of immense
continents avoided subduction at plate
boundaries and resisted the relentless
onslaught of wind water and ice that
have been the death of so many younger
than itself so perhaps it's not
surprising that rocks like this are
incredibly rare what may be more
surprising is that however hard
geologists have searched they can't find
anything older
the acosta nice is old but it's not as
old as the earth itself meteorites tell
us that the earth formed around the Sun
4.5 4 billion years ago and yet the
oldest rocks are more than half a
billion years a younger more than 10% of
Earth's history is missing from the
record books and half a billion years is
a long time it's the same amount of time
that animals plants all multicellular
life has been on the planet so what
could be missing from this first huge
chunk of Earth's history what was going
on for all that time
[Music]
more than 500 billion years before the
first crystals of the acosta nice took
shape the earth was born the newborn son
shown a weak and watery light over its
protoplanetary disk where gravity pulled
specks of dust then tiny pebbles larger
rocks and eventually huge proto planets
together eventually a single roughly
spherical body took shape about 150
million kilometres from the Sun inside
this newborn earth heavier elements like
iron and nickel felt the irresistible
tug of gravity and descended deep into
the heart of the planet where
temperatures and pressures soared the
earth differentiated into core and
mantle the surface of the planet exposed
to the cold vacuum of space cooled and
solidified into a thin igneous crust for
time everything went well for the
nascent earth until catastrophe struck
another proto planet FEA struck
scientists aren't sure if they hit the
earth with just a glancing blow or if it
was totaled in a head-on crash but in
either case this was no ordinary
bombardment
with the force of a billion trillion
tons Thea plows into the earth the
intense pressure sees temperatures soar
to several thousand degrees Celsius
solid rock turns first to liquid and
then to vapor both planets crusts are
stripped away and huge chunks of their
Mantle's are hurled out into space as
the dust settles this earth of 4.4
billion years ago would be
unrecognizable to a traveller from today
glowing red from within the molten
mantle uses through the cracks of black
glossy crust
it's girdled by a thick tumultuously of
rock and dust the disgorged remnants of
both victims Mantle's now frozen
unlocked in orbit around the shattered
earth but no observer from our world
would last long on the planet's surface
barely any atmosphere remains any gases
that had cloned to the earth when it
first formed would have been blown away
by the spectacular force of the
collision the rock ejected from the
mantle rains down to the surface as
molten droplets dust pebbles and
boulders and the skies light up both
night and day as the rocks in the
encircling ring jostle and collide with
one another like waves on a storm-tossed
sea
night and day themselves come at
breakneck speed to the immense energy
impacted by failures collision sent our
planet reeling now completing an entire
rotation in just five hours eventually
some semblance of order begins to
descend in Earth's skies small rocks
collide and stick together and attract
larger rocks which themselves have the
gravity to attract more of the orbiting
debris before long a single body comes
to rain sweeping up the rocks and dust
and clearing out Earth's skies the moon
is fawn but it's not the moon we
recognize today early on it glows dull
red is the internal heat from its
accretion slowly escapes into space as
it cools it becomes a relatively
featureless ball of grey rock pockmarked
by only a few craters from collisions
later on in its formation like the earth
it's spinning rapidly and this moon
looms large in Earth's skies it's ten
times closer than today
and from the planet's surface appears
about 15 times as wide with an arm
outstretched it would take an entire
palm to hide it from view
the earth now has a satellite weighing a
million trillion tons orbiting just
20,000 miles away and this new neighbor
has a profound impact on our world
Thayer's impact injected an immense
amount of heat into the earth the
surface itself may drop below a thousand
degrees celsius allowing a thin crust to
solidify but throughout the interior the
molten rock is still a roiling ocean and
the new moon huddled so close to the
earth can tug on that inner ocean like
it tugs on our surface water oceans
today the immense tidal forces are
enough to deform the entire planet
bulging it outwards cracking and
splitting the thin surface crust as the
semi molten rock swells and surges up as
the Earth and Moon rotate around one
another this towering planetary bulge
rolls over the planet in an unstoppable
wave splintering the crust with every
rotation molten lava spills through the
cracks to freeze with a glassy luster
and then be broken anew mere hours later
this is new earth the earth of 4.2
billion years ago if a traveler were to
visit it could easily be described as
the very definition of Hell itself
scorching temperatures make life here
unbearable the surface itself is not
stable riven by lava floods and
fountains of magma there is no air a
sickening March of day and night
overseen by the blood-red featureless
face of a malevolent puppeteer this is
the Hadean the first of Earth's great
eons an age defined by its resemblance
to Hades the underworld of Greek
mythology land of the dead
truly nothing can survive on this
hostile hellish planet but yet this time
will pass as the Earth and Moon world
through space locked in a gravitational
dance through the heavens they trade
angular momentum slowly gradually they
begin to slow down
the Earth's spin slows and days and
nights grow longer the moon's spin also
slows and the same gravitational forces
that wracked the earth now lock the moon
into precise synchrony the satellite
becomes tidally locked taking exactly
the same amount of time to rotate on its
axis as it does to orbit the earth
destined to see only one of its phases
from here on out the moon begins
drifting away from the earth at a rate
of about four centimeters a year and is
still doing so today
[Music]
back in the Hadean as the millennia past
the moon's constant face gradually
shrinks from view and with it its
violent tug on the battered earth the
tidal wave of molten rock diminishes and
eventually the thickening crust triumphs
the surface of the earth is stable for
now
but things aren't so placid beneath the
surface all that heat from the planets
initial accretion and from the
catastrophe moon-forming impact is still
trapped within Earth's mantle it Royals
with vast convection currents sending
plumes of semi molten rock
thousands of miles upwards from the
diabolically hopped core when this
material reaches the crust it punches
through exploiting cracks and weaknesses
in the newly formed rock to unleash
great floods of lava that flow like
mighty rivers and pool in hellish
burning oceans these early volcanoes
aren't like those of the later classic
strata cone variety that blow themselves
apart when they erupt their great
shallow shields that sprawl across the
landscape like weeping wounds losing
layer upon layer of sticky black lava
but it's not just lava that these giant
shield volcanoes discharge as liquid
rock pours over the surface gases are
spewing up into the air nitrogen carbon
dioxide sulfur dioxide and superheated
water vapor all separated from the
mantle rock and follow the volcano
plumbing up and out of the earth but
they don't have the power to escape the
planet's gravity the gases cling to the
surface building up mixing together and
creating Earth's first real atmosphere a
blanket of gas that swaddles the
planet's surface
finally protecting it from the abyss of
space
[Music]
hi in the young atmosphere temperatures
cool enough for water to condense and
the first clouds form high and low
pressure systems develop and winds blow
between them on the highest peaks the
first rain falls
but this is no summer rainstorm Hadean
rain burns chemical reactions in the
cloud tops sees carbon dioxide reacting
with water to make a potent acid acid
rain falls and acid rivers flow and
before long acid oceans start to pool
meanwhile the turbulent mantle
convection of the world begins to exert
a more profound effect on the Earth's
surface as streams of upwelling mantle
can't escape through increasingly thick
volcanic crust they spread out sideways
flowing as vast and unbelievably
powerful currents just beneath the young
crust the rock above is torn apart and
carried along with it where the huge
rocky rafts diverge more lava pours out
to fill the space and where they collide
they're crumpled and folded uplifted and
subducted mountain chains buckle upwards
solid rocks splintering and shearing an
excruciatingly slow motion while magma
is injected from below all this is
powered by the irresistible flow of the
Earth's interior as plate tectonics
begin
plate tectonics sees the creation of new
kinds of rock those of the igneous
variety sitting inside the crust cooling
slowly eventually forming granites acid
rivers and rain gradually wear away the
mountains even as they are still forming
over time turning them into grains of
sand that will one day become sandstone
and deep in the heart of the mountains
the rocks are so crushed and baked that
they changed their structure and
chemistry altogether they become
metamorphic rocks like nice it was in
the heart of one of these first
mountains four billion years ago but a
rock formed that was destined to stand
the test of time while those around it
have long since melted subducted
transformed and eroded away the heart of
this mountain outlives them all
[Music]
today it's it's resolute under a
Midnight Sun protected as much by its
isolation as its mineral durability it's
been transported around the globe buried
deep exhumed worn down by glaciers
encrusted by lichens and attacked by
geologists hammers but the Acosta nice
has survived 90% of Earth's history it's
the last remnant of our newly forged
planet and a record of the hell that
reigned for 500 million years if only it
could tell us what it witnessed for the
remaining 4 billion
next time we follow the story of our
planet during its earliest epochs
looking at how the oceans first formed
and how planetary bombardment from the
heavens might have changed our world
forever
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to Like and
subscribe tell us what you think in the
comments and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you